so what better way to get tony stark out  of the picture than to just let him die  than to not step in than to not do  anything to save the life of tony stark  the idea of captain america going back  into the past living his life with peggy  carter and then basically growing old  that's part of king's plan because now  captain america is out of the picture  that when you look at the fantastic four  which presumably took off in the 1960s  and whether we go with my theory which  is that they're literally just trying to  find a way back but they just keep  ending up in alternate realities they  came to conquer allowed that to happen  he allowed the fantastic four to end up  in the time stream because he knows that  they're gonna get lost there that it  allows them to be removed from the  equation all these things the way that  things have unfolded have actually been  allowed to unfold by cain the conqueror